the same people that said I don't know  why maybe because they work so hard in  2020 and 2021 I can guarantee you people  didn't work hard in 2020 and 20. it's  the least working years in the last two  three four decades because they got away  with everything working from home ain't  nobody very few people in 2020 and 2021  were working harder than they work in  the 2019 listen it's hard you cannot be  productive if you're working and your  bed is right there the TV's there and  the couch is there yeah and the  refrigerator also the bong is right  there they're close by the alcohol  people are coming you're doing a zoom  with them any reason why your eyes are  so red yeah it's just been a very  stressful day